merry Merry Christmas everyone I hope
you're having a marvelous first day of
Christmas you know there there are 12
Days of Christmas people they want to
take down the Christmas tree at 5:00 on
Christmas Day itself it goes on much
much longer there there is so much about
the Christmas season Advent The 12 Days
of Christmas the whole even why we
celebrate Christmas on December 25th
that is confusing to many modern people
I consider it all part of the war on
Christmas
I I like to consider myself a general in
the war on Christmas but I I decided we
need to bring in some outside support
here because I don't what do I really
know about any of this so I figured I
would bring in an expert on Christmas
and that would be his Excellency Bishop
Robert Baron Bishop Baron thank you so
much for coming on Michael good to be
with you Merry Christmas to you Merry
Christmas uh wonderful that you could
make the time I I actually want to talk
specifically about time and about
history and about this claim that
one uh Christians just invented
Christmas and made it this time of year
to to steal a holiday from the pagans
that's one claim I often he two that
there's no good reason that they picked
December 25th other than you know there
were there were pagan holidays and
winter solstice and three that it
doesn't really matter when we celebrate
Christmas doesn't matter when this stuff
happened forget about history all
together
let's just you know en enjoy the good
feelings of the Season or something like
that uh in in no particular order uh
feel free to give me your
thoughts well as you suggest the
standard View and I would have learned
it certainly as a student is that we
don't really know for sure when Jesus
was born exactly and December 25th
corresponds to you know the Pagan feast
day of the Soul Invictus right the the
all-conquering son so the return of the
light there's a there's a beautiful
Association there of you know Christ the
light of the world Etc and you know that
that could be the case we don't we don't
know that's a basic fact um another
angle on it though is that some suggest
you know the Feast of the anunciation
March 25th so nine months prior to
December 25th is actually older than the
the feast assigned for Christmas and so
is there some ground if if there was a
some reason to believe that was the case
historically then wouldn't it make sense
that December 25th would be the the day
of jesus' birth but I think the The
Wider Point you're making is is the most
important one namely that Christianity
is an historical religion we are not a
Mythic system so I love the myths I I
love myths of all the different you know
cultures and they're fascinating and
they tell fundamental truth that's the
great virtue of the myths about nature
about the cosmos about human psychology
Etc but the mark of the myth is always
that little phrase you know once upon a
time or in that time they usually use
the Latin inot temporary or I've often
said the Contemporary version is in a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
that's a way of signaling I'm dealing
with a myth here because I'm not trying
to situate it historically no one
wonders you know who now who was the
king of you know Greece when Hercules
was cleaning the aan Stables or it's
just a it's just a category error
because a myth deals with kind of
transhistorical
truths then there's Christianity which
is a stubbornly historical religion
it's not just making generic claims
about our psychology or about the cosmos
or The rhythms of nature it's making
very specific claims about something
that happened I think of it Michael
every single Sunday when we recite the
Creed and we say that little line he was
crucified under Pontius pilot uh we're
not talking about the cross as an
archetypal symbol we're not talking
about the mystery of death to life no no
we're talking about this particular
first century Jew who was crucified in
the Roman manner under this Governor
whose existence can be verified outside
the Bible named Pontius
Pilatus that grounds Christianity in a
way that mattered immensely from the
beginning the first Christians knew how
vitally important was that these things
happened you know so there's a a
constant
temptation to reduce Christianity to a
Mythic system and it should be um
vigorously
resisted right
because one often hears Christianity
referred to as the true myth you know
we're not denying that there is this
Mythic significance that there's that
there's this incredible uh you know
semiotic significance to the cross and
to the mysteries of life and death and
even when we read in the gospels we read
inot tempor but then what happens right
after inot tempor we hear yeus Dixit you
know Christ said and now we're we're
we've lost the the realm of mere poetry
or or high pros and we're now into the
realm of Journalism something that
really happened with a real man among
other men and women in a real place in
real time and we can trace that
historicity all the way back I I love
that you mention the uh Coincidence of
of the Annunciation you know N9 months
prior to Christmas I think it was St
hippitus of Rome who pointed that out
and even Pope Benedict the the 16th
observed that while one recognizes these
beautiful parallels between the Pagan
feasts and Christmas yeah it's very
difficult to argue now that the Pagan
Feast predate the Soul Invictus predated
uh Christmas because the earliest
evidence we have of both in a in a
calendar is from the chronography of 350
before I think it is and so it might
just as well be the case that the feast
ofct went the other way around exactly
and and what's so beautiful about it to
me I suppose is that when you have the
historicity you don't have to lose the
myth and yeah and and that I suppose in
a broader view the Nativity and the
crucifixion and the resurrection it is
it is the Crux of History literally it's
what it's what gives me me and redeems
all of the history secular and and
otherwise that we have around
us no quite right and you were referring
at least implicitly there to CS Lewis
who who made that observation that you
those who say Christianity is just
another myth haven't read many myths and
and Lewis himself was a great expert in
Mythic literature but it's the same
Lewis who makes that remark if you want
it's the true myth you know uh it's not
just one more Mythic telling among many
so you could say remember this goes back
few years when I was uh just out of just
ordained Joseph Campbell came on the
scene and talked about the myths of the
world and he used the phrase the monom
myth he felt that that really all the
cultures are telling one great story and
I mean look that might be true at some
archetypal level but you can't say
Christianity is just one more iteration
of the monom myth because we're we're up
against the stubborn historicity of it
um elements of truth from the mono myth
that are also in the gospels sure but
it's the true myth it's it's the myth
that sprang to life so Lewis talks about
the the good dreams of the human race
that the myths represent the human race
dreaming about what will be accomplished
in Christ and so they're anticipating
him and that's why when Christ is
announced a lot of cultures said oh yeah
I I recognize that I I understand that
because their imagination had been
evangelized through the myths so I think
that's a great way of combining the two
ideas we we don't have to just reject
the Mythic tradition but we see it as a
true myth even I was just flying back
from
India where I was I flew out for a
friend's wedding and by the way a big
reminder to people be very careful if
you're going to become friends with
Indians because one day they might
expect you to fly to India for their
wedding but we it was a lovely wedding
and it was actually in the more cathol
state in carola where legend or or maybe
history but at least Legend say St
Thomas St Thomas landed Pope Benedict
also well I think that's a good that's
credible well that's I hope I hope it's
credible because I like to think that I
was there where my confirmation Saint
landed I think it was Pope Benedict
suggested he he he really only made it
to Northwestern India Pakistan say and
that but but I'd prefer to say that I I
was walking the ground that St Thomas
did yeah and but on on my flight back I
I was reading uh some church fathers and
I was reading this great book about
Dante you know I love Dante and I figure
this will be some indulgent reading
especially in Advent time and something
that Dante does is he he gets into not
only religious history and not only myth
also but but secular history you know
you you see these confounding figures
these old Romans you know KO for
instance in in purgatory plays a really
big role
and it it's a reminder that you know the
historical aspects of Christianity are
not just confined to the faith or to
some tiny little sliver of history but
to all of it then then I was reminded of
this bizarre fact of Christmas which is
that at the time of the Nativity at the
time of the Christ's birth you have
sitting on the throne in Rome the the
the man referred to as the son of the
Divine the fil D and then born in
Bethlehem you have the Fus day the Son
of God the the uh Ascension to the
throne of Caesar Augustus filus Divi was
heralded by by a star by a a comment uh
the the Nativity of Our Lord heralded by
another star in Bethlehem uh the the
filus Devi on the throne in Rome haralds
the PX Romana the Roman peace the the
the Nativity of Our Lord Heralds the pox
Mundi you know the whole peace of the
world
the if a Hollywood screenwriter could
put that story on paper you wouldn't
believe it you'd say it's to on the nose
we can't and yet that really
happened yeah and you mentioned Pope
Benedict a couple times and you know go
back to that famously controversial
reagens BG address he gave that was
misconstrued in a thousand different
ways his main point there was it's
remarkably significant that Christianity
says in Jesus the logos became flesh
because what that does it permits a
dialogue literally dialogue with the
Sciences with history with culture with
law with all the deepest aspirations of
the human heart because we're what we're
longing for whether we're in a cultural
framework a legal framework a political
framework we're looking for Logos in
some way we're looking for mind for
reason and so Christianity doesn't have
to position itself as sequestered over
on the side of things no it's at the
heart of of everything because if the
logos that every scientist see is
seeking every artist is seeking every
decent person is seeking that's the
logos that became flesh in Jesus so it
enables this marvelous cultural
conversation which is marked uh
Christianity at its best from the
beginning the point he was making there
in Regensburg is a really vital one in a
time of religious and cultural conflict
um and if religion is seen as dangerous
you know to our political arrangements
and all that no no it belongs at the
heart of all of it because of the unique
claim being made by Christianity Loos
logos the beginning of John's gospel
that matters immensely for our
conversation today I I love that you
mention the rensburg address because the
part that got yeah the the the late Pope
in trouble was he he pointed out that
the Christian conception of God is the
The God Who is the logos who is the
Divine logic of the universe whereas the
Muslim conception and he he cited ham
this medieval Islamic scholar um is that
Allah is utterly Transcendent such that
if Allah were to order a follower to
worship an idol he could do that and
that would be understandable within the
Muslim conception of God that would not
be understandable within the Christian
conception of God which is a perfectly
fine point that he made and I thought it
was silly that he got in trouble for it
but but it's extraordinarily significant
because if our God is the God that is
the logos then that means it all has to
make sense you know that the whole story
has to make sense and so you mention in
the beginning of the Gospel of John you
see Christ identified with the logos in
the beginning of the synoptic gospels
what do you get you get history you get
a a genealogy you get so how does one
how does one make sense of of those two
Origin
stories well I I mean I i' read them
together as as the Bible compels us to
the genealogy accounts are meant to
ground Us in um Israelite history I
think it's wonderful that the first page
you see in the New Testament is this
long complex genealogy three sets of 14
Generations 14 being the number that
corresponds in Hebrew to DED or David So
Matthew is saying David David David has
come um but you can't avoid Israel if
you don't understand Jesus see that
grounds him in in history he's not a
Mythic archetypal figure he's the
culmination of this
long Royal and complex and lomy history
of of Israel but it's that same Jesus
who is Uber particular he's an Israelite
came through this long particular
tradition who's also the logos the logos
the reason behind all things is made
plain to us in this baby who's the
culmination of the long history of
Israel God speaks his word in all things
which every scientist has to assume
right there's an intelligibility in
everything so God is speaking in all
things but he spoke in varied and
fragmentary ways to our ancestors but
now in the fullness of time he's spoken
by means of his son by means of his word
and so it's the it's
the what appears as the culmination of
Israel is in fact the logos by which all
things are informed I think that's the
beautiful coming together if you want of
a more Greek and a more Hebrew view that
are right on display in the New
Testament I love that point you just
made too which is every scientist
whether he knows it or not believes this
everyone they have to otherwise nothing
we say would be understandable one to
another intelligibility of the world and
that's that's rosinger too one of the
best Arguments for God's existence is
the radical and Universal
intelligibility of the world world how
do you explain that without recourse to
some sort of creative intelligence which
has thought the world into being the
world is not dumbly there it's
intelligibly there which is why the
inquiring mind goes out to meet it ainus
says that you know that there's this
wonderful congruence between the seeking
mind and the intelligible World well how
do you explain that without some kind of
recourse to logos now the genius of
Christianity so any Greek philosopher
might have said that you know Pythagoras
would have known that Plato would have
known that but who would have guessed
that that logos is most fully revealed
in this baby in Bethlehem um wrapped in
swaddling cloves and lying in a Manger
that the logos by which the whole
universe is governed is something like
the self-emptying love of God that's the
genius and poetry of Christianity that
it brings those two things together if
you resolve it one-sidedly on the side
of history or one-sidedly on the side of
philosophy you're going to miss it it's
the coming together of those two that's
so powerful and and to think about the
symmetry of that in history yeah that
one would read only in the very finest
myth or see in only the most significant
aspects of History namely yeah you have
Adam from Adam comes Eve and then we
have the fall of Man because of the
Disobedience of Adam and Eve and then in
the new Adam our Lord and in the new EVE
our lady you have the new Adam coming
from the new Eve and you have the just
as we have the fall of mankind because
of their Disobedience to God of our
first parents so you have the Redemption
of mankind in our lady acquiescing and
saying yes I'm the Lord's handmade uh be
it done according to his will and and
and then you have this little baby from
the the our oldest first father you have
this little baby as the new Adam it's
just so beautiful and it really happened
and even that kind of perspective on it
I I fear is somewhat lacking in the the
even the Christian Consciousness today
to say nothing of non-christians who've
probably never heard of such a
thing well you've been reading ST irus
it sounds like because that was irus I
mean look very early on he's a second
century figure Ires dies around the year
200 he's writing in the60s 170s the time
of of Marcus Aurelius but irenaeus I
mean he saw all of this and I think one
of the real seminal Geniuses of our
tradition you know we say Augustine and
origin of course but I think irenaeus is
one of the top three figures among the
church fathers and he saw all those
parallels that you were pointing out and
let me stay with Mary for a second
because you're right the new EVE he was
very strong on that but look at Mary in
um in Luke's gospel is presented is the
new ark of the covenant because she
Bears within her the presence of God as
the ark bore the presence of the Ten
Commandments and that's echoed all
throughout that story most beautifully I
think when she goes into the Hill
Country of Judah and we'd say okay it's
a geographical reference it is but it's
also a reference to the Old Testament
because when the ark was lost through a
long series of events it ends up in the
home of this man in the Hill Country of
Judea same phrase Mary goes there um
when David came to get the ark he brings
it back to Jerusalem and he does this
this festive dance in front of the Ark
right well what happens when um uh John
the Baptist in the womb of his mother
hears the greeting of Mary but he leaps
in her womb well the father saw that as
a recapitulation of David's dance so
it's a new David dancing in the presence
of the Ark of the Covenant um they
didn't miss any of that stuff I mean
they they saw Israel coming to its
fulfillment and again that's a point we
have to make over and over again Michael
I think is without Israel you will not
understand Jesus and when you try and it
happens all the time you turn Jesus into
a um a sage he's a a wise speaker of
Timeless truths he's he's one moral
Exemplar among many well who cares who
cares yeah there's a thousand such
figures but when you see him through the
through the lens of Israel and as Paul
said he's the yes to all the promises
made to Israel ah now we get him now we
understand him um that Israelite side of
Christmas I think needs to be recovered
it seems to be a
peculiar uh eccentricity of our age that
there is a a desire to
dehistoricized judaize I'd be more
particular and I I don't want to be too
provocative but go back to the early
20th century when a lot of the um
historical critical figures so these are
biblical commentators in a more liberal
mostly Protestant tradition but a lot of
them were coming up out of a frankly
anti-semitic uh Viewpoint some I don't
want to overgeneralize but some were
even sympathetic with the Nazis and and
there was even when I was learning the
Bible as a young you know seminarian
there was a somewhat anti-jewish uh
reading of Jesus you see it in biblical
scholarship to the present day when you
turn him into he's a stoic philosopher
or he's a you know he's another Mythic
commentator no no he's the yes to all
the promises made to Israel only then
will you really get him right right that
that's that's a great point I never made
a a uh connection here with the sort of
critical historicist uh school that
basically denies all of these concrete
historical facts TR it to the beginning
of the 19 Century someone like fried
schocker who's the founder of modern
liberal protestantism from schacher all
the way through boltman and those people
you do find a certain anti-jewish
Prejudice and so you know boltman puts
it very much in dialogue with the kind
of the Greek uh the helenistic world uh
one of the marks of the last maybe 30
years biblical scholarship is the re
judaizing of Jesus and I think that's
borne tremendous fruit well and speaking
of the the the Israel of the old test
Testament I've noticed one argument
against modern Christians we hear and
it's I guess a kind of historical
argument is well we eat shellfish you
know we we cut our hair and so we're
violating the laws of God and and
furthermore how dare you Christians
insist upon any kind of moral law
because you know you've uh violated some
obscure passage of Leviticus and uh it
seems to me a beautiful thing though
somewhat unknown these days that the
Divine Law is three-fold perhaps as we
might expect moral and ceremonial and
civil and that that you know I the other
day I mentioned something about the
natural law people looked at me as
though I had three heads you know that
they never heard that there might that
the moral law might be distinct uh from
a ceremonial law or a or a Judicial law
you're you're absolutely right about
that and you hear that argument in
different forms all the time today
people need to read that wonderful
section in the second part of the Suma
of acquaintance when he makes that
distinction between the moral ceremonial
and what calls judical precepts of the
law those latter two he said are
subsumed they're they're kind of seen as
symbolic anticipations of what will
happen in Jesus especially on his cross
so they're not negated they're they're
kind of raised up into a higher
expression whereas the moral law remains
intact in fact the Ten Commandments
acinus construes as basic expressions of
of the natural law well that remains the
case all the way through by the way I
just gave a sermon on this recently a
lot of the debate in the Reformation
around Paul in regard to the law I think
can be cleared up if we make these right
distinctions we're not saved by The
Works of the law I think Paul is
referring to aquinus as you know judical
and ceremonial precepts it doesn't mean
we abandon the moral precepts because
read it in in Paul to the Romans where
he's so strong on you know it's not the
law and all that but heck by the end of
Romans he's
he's happily welcoming all these
expressions of the moral law so they're
not repugnant to the the work of
Salvation at all right uh but that
distinction is lost in a lot of people
unfortunately well and even uh here we
see a distinction between the natural
law and uh as other aspects of
Revelation and it reminds me of a line
from the first Vatican Council which
says that the existence of God can be
known with certainty by the natural
light of reason for natural reason yeah
and this today is shocking to so many
people who throw their hands up they say
you know Wellman who we can't really
ever know if God exists you know past
the bong and it's this real subjectivist
sort of hippie dippy talk but that was
not the view for most of History we did
believe that we can know the existence
of God with certainty but we can't
necessarily know very much about God or
we can't know how to serve God in this
world or we can't know the specific
into
without reason without ration it's not
Revelation without reason as many modern
people would like to characterize
religion it's
both both and that's you know Thomas
aquinus and all the great figures in our
tradition faith and reason and you're
right um Thomas would would refer to
Arguments for God's existence and all
that as part of the prula F right the
preambles to the faith but you might say
the conditions for the possibility of
taking Revelation seriously so if you
know you have some sense from reason of
God's existence God's attributes and all
that well then it makes perfect sense
that God would speak that God would
reveal himself to us in a personal way
so I think for example you know you and
I have met a few times and i' I've come
to know you through videos and all that
and so my reason can say a number of
things about you and I could look you up
on Google and Facebook and and my mind
could construe something true about you
right but I'm not going to know you no
way unless you ultimately Dain to speak
to me from your heart right uh not that
I'm expecting you to do that right now
but I mean only if we became
exceptionally good friends and that you
decide I'm going to tell this person
something about myself that he would
never know otherwise right he he would
only know it if I revealed it that to me
is Perfect Analogy for the faith reason
we can know a lot of things about God I
think through our reason and God
Delights in that God wants us to come to
know him and then Paul says that Romans
1:20 I mean through the visible things
of the world the invisible things of God
are known great great and pagans can do
that and modern pagans can do that so
that's terrific but but the claim of the
church still startling is that this God
whom we know through
reason spoke to us Deus Dix it God has
spoken and he's revealed certain things
about himself that we would never have
known otherwise that come from the heart
of God and most fully in his son right
he spoke in varied and fragmentary ways
but now in the fullness of time he's
spoken through his son and it's like
that baby in Bethlehem like that
poor destitute figure on the cross but
but that's God
speaking his deepest heart to us you
know that's the again Paradox in poetry
of Christianity we don't isue reason but
we go beyond it and we listen
attentively as God speaks his heart to
us and and it's very difficult for some
people you know very good friend of mine
of many years raised Jewish uh read St
Augustine decides to convert to
Catholicism but then I caught up with
him maybe a year after he had this
Revelation and I said oh well have you
done it and they said I haven't I said
well why is that I said you know you
you're no longer persuaded he said no
I'm persuaded I am entirely
intellectually persuaded not just of
Christianity broadly even but
specifically of Catholicism he said I'm
totally persuaded he said I can't bring
myself to pray to a man it's I just
can't get myself to do it and I said but
you're persuaded it's all true I said he
said yes I said you're persuaded that
you need baptism he said I am I said how
do you even cross the street if you
think all that but you haven't done it
and he said very
carefully but he couldn't he said it and
and then I was reminded that it the
Incarnation is a stumbling block for
people
yeah no and in a way fair enough it
always has been right you know that God
becomes one of us God takes to himself a
human nature to use for his iconic
purposes and that this uh this incarnate
God dies and Rises to save us from our
sins that's a weird story yeah you know
and that's why Paul Paul knew it right
this is this is folly to the Greeks and
a stumbling block to the Jews which for
him meant everyone's GNA hate this story
yeah no one's gon to get this story
right but of course that's part of the
weirdly the convincing power of it you
know uh if it was just a conventional
story that we could kind of figure out
on our own what's the likelihood that
that's God speaking to us but this
supremely strange story um
The supremely Strange World of the Bible
that opens up to us to me that has its
own sort of convincing power but you
know at the end of the day and this is
every single one of our great figures
would say this at the end of the day
it's the holy spirit that has to convict
us um we can't aggressively think our
way through it uh we can think about it
and we should but we can't compel this
thing it's it's like any relationship
you know I can't compel someone to be my
friend yeah uh I can make offers of
friendship I I can even speak my heart
you know to someone but if they don't
want to be my friend I I can't compel it
and the same is true of God God wants to
be our friend and so he can't coers Us
in that
relationship that's beautifully put and
even this point about how odd it all is
you know a priest friend of mine in New
York once said he said people want
really clear religion they want just
five bullet points or something he said
shallows are clear profound things are
are a little murky sometimes they're a
little more obscure you know so sorry go
ahead but the best analogy there is
chesterton's about the the key you know
that the reason a key works is it's like
really complicated and and if it were
simpler it wouldn't be effective because
anyone could then you know pick the lock
it's a very weirdly complex convoluted
thing that will open this equally weird
convoluted l
and so life is very strange and complex
and God gives us a very strange and
complex key to open the door and the key
is I would say Israel culminating in the
mashiach in the Messiah of Israel that's
the key that he handed to people like
Peter and Paul you know and who hand
that key onto us that's the key that
opens the door so then looking ahead to
the rest of the
story we know how the story
begins we know the pivot of History we
know the big turn of the story which
we're celebrating now and then we we
know how the story ends though there are
some gaps to fill in I suppose in the
middle we've just come out of Advent
we're now beginning the even though
people treat December 1st as you know
the first day of Christmas and it goes
on for 25 days once heard modern
religion that's not my own line but uh
described as the old religion had first
the fast and then the feast now we have
uh first the feast and then The Hangover
over uh but but we're looking ahead now
and even coming out of Advent people are
awaiting the birth of this little baby
Jesus but that's not what we're awaiting
now we're still in a period of awaiting
something and it we're still in a period
of awaiting Jesus but we're we're now
awaiting the second coming and so
traditionally during Advent one
considers the four final things death
judgment Heaven and Hell which is why
it's a penitential period people don't
really treat it that way anymore uh what
do we do as we await now this this
second Advent which is going to be uh
more significant perhaps even than the
first right there's a vigil quality to
Christian Life That's why um a season
like Advent name something permanent
within Christianity our whole life is is
a vigil all of the last 2,000 years have
been a vigil so we wait in joyful hope
for the coming of our savior think of
the last lines of the Bible you know you
know marinata come Lord Jesus um we're
we're in like this permanent stance of
of vigil keeping and that's I think a
lot of the spiritual life I I used to
teach it under that rubric is we have to
learn to be
vigilant uh we keep the candle burning
that means we're alert and awake even
when we don't feel like it even when we
are growing tired we're growing
indifferent I've been waiting so long
yeah but stay at your post you know stay
at your post you're you're it hasn't
come perfectly yet and and that's
obvious to everybody you know that the
world is not perfect and final justice
has not been realized and wicked people
prosper and good people suffer and all
those things wars and rumors of wars and
all of it continue so it hasn't arrived
yet but Christians are are Vigilant and
we keep the you know it's like the uh
the five wise virgins right that that
have oil in their lamps because it's a
long wait and so the foolish virgins
fall asleep and so when the master comes
they're not able to greet him that names
a permanent quality of the Christian
Life is Vigilant waiting for the Lord
and it's a great discipline you know
Michael because again we want to be in
command of the spiritual life like we
are anything else I want to get in shape
I want to learn how to play the piano I
want to learn how to play golf and I'm
in charge and let me get my book and
figure it out but it'll never work that
way with with religion with the
Christian religion you you have to wait
remember in Dante you mentioned him um
there are those in in anti-
purgatory who waited too long in life
and so in before they even begin
Purgatory yeah they just have to wait
and how long I don't know I don't know
you just got to wait and that also names
something very important in the
spiritual life sometimes you just have
to wait for Grace um and and in a way
that that is the whole of your spiritual
life is is come Lord Jesus come I'm
waiting for you to act in my life so I
think that's okay that's a it's a
challenge but it's a very important U
aspect of the Christian Life right right
that's that's beautifully put and now
I'm reminded even of those early contos
of purgatory where people wait around a
little bit too long these these people
who they've waited in their lives and
and Dante falls into this a little bit
too where he says you know I've just
been through this AR journey of gone
through the very pit of Hell climbed up
through Satan and he just wants a little
comfort you know he just wants a little
rest or something and he's reminded of
one of his own lines of poetry very
famous
line because Dante wrote all this famous
love poetry you know uh love which uh
reasons in my mind you know and he's
going on about his love and he's but
he's forgetting his end so he's getting
a little bit too complacent he's not
looking forward to he's going to go all
the way up Mount per atory as well so so
we remember sorry no no that reminded me
of the very beginning of the of the
whole Comedia when he's wandered off the
straight path and then he sees the hill
covered in in sunlight and oh that's it
there's my goal and I'm just going to go
and then of course he's blocked by the
three beasts that represent the three
modalities of sin and that's the person
that wants to rush his way through the
spiritual life no no you need to do a
lot of work that's what that's saying to
Dante you need to do a lot of to work
before you're ready for this vision of
God and that's the that's the whole
aesthetic dimension of the Christian
Life that we know we don't like that's
true we want feast all the time but much
of life is this aesthetic pres
preparation um and and this willingness
to accept the arduousness of the journey
um and that's Dante it's it's a long
track as you say all the way down
through hell not partway all the way
down and you got to see Satan at the
very center of of your own sinful life
generating all of the the coldness and
wickedness of of sin and then you got to
patiently climb up Mount Purgatory so
that's a um permanently valuable Insight
uh but I think today we want to just
rush through the spiritual life oh yeah
let me figure this out and just give me
the know the book to follow no no you
got to wait and you got to you got to go
through a journey it might be the
consequence of people no longer reading
Dante or reading the church fathers or
reading the school men you know St
Thomas aquinus or reading the Bible
certainly but they're all reading
self-help books and it's ironic because
if all you ever read is self-help you're
never going to help yourself at all
right well just think of you know we're
coming out of the Advent season and and
the great Advent himym okom OK Come
Emanuel and Ransom captive Israel well
that's someone who is um who was held
captive taken captive and held for
ransom maybe in a distant country maybe
chained in place and completely
incapable of saving himself and all he
can do is hope come come can someone
come and Ransom me well that's all of us
sinners you know we're not able to lift
ourselves out of our situation that's
why God had to come to us and come all
the way down there's the meaning of the
Cross you know there there's as Paul
says Christ becoming sin on the cross
not a sinner if he's a sinner then he
needs to be saved too but he becomes sin
on the cross goes all the way into our
dysfunction and then lifts us up through
his grace that's Christianity it's not a
self-help program I it's it's not that
that's pelagianism that's why Augustine
fought that battle it was a very
important battle because he realized
Pelagius was a very Charming figure and
and a very bright man and saw something
true but if he was basically right
Christianity falls apart because then
we're just one more you know uh the
classical philosophers had that enough
knowledge and enough habituation to
Virtue you know you'll be fine uh
modernity has its own version we have
our own versions of it and then there's
Christianity that we're not saved by any
of that but we're saved by the baby
wrapped in swaddling clothes and lying
in a Manger go where he is go where he
is we're saved by the destitute man on
the cross go go to him you know um
that's a that's a permanently
countercultural message uh but
especially
now Bishop Baron your Excellency Merry
Christmas thank you for coming
Merry Christmas to you Michael
[Music]
thanks